hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the second part of his discourse on
method before he gives us the famous
four rules of the Cartesian method
Descartes is going to talk a little bit
about why he formulated those rules what
his motivation was and this is one that
I think could apply to many of us he's
talking about why and how one could
reconstruct the foundations of knowledge
and he provides us with several
interesting analogies he talks about
city planning and he also talks about
legislation and these are somewhat
connected with each other legislation
has to do with creating not just laws
individually but with with the structure
of the entire society city planning has
to do with the space in which we live so
these are actually very important and
and how are these similar to developing
fields of knowledge well that that's
what we'll we'll see as Descartes sets
it out for us so he he's got this great
example of old cities he begins by
talking about ancient cities in which
people have been adding things and the
streets originally you know may have
been trails you know and if you've ever
been in an old city like that the city
that's existed for three hundred four
hundred five hundred years you can
relate very easily to what Descartes is
talking about here you know exam for
example in the Midwest many of our
cities are much newer and they're laid
out on grid patterns so it's very easy
to get around that's a more rational
structure and so Descartes says things
that are produced by the hands of a
number of different people often have a
less coherent less rational structure to
them so these old cities grow over time
being added to being subtracted from
occasionally right things collapse and
you build over them as a matter of fact
you may be building up on
of old structures as well and so they
tend to be fairly badly laid out because
they're oftentimes developed for
technologies that are out of date you
know you know a city that that
originally had its streets laid out
primarily so that you can get to another
city or just for horses and carriages
when we shift to the automobile it may
not be structured quite quite as well
and so he goes on and he says that this
is the case not only with cities but
also with buildings you know when when
several people are working on the
building that can be a problem think
about additions so one of the phrases
that he has in here that I particularly
like is that he talks about you know
when we when we look at these sorts of
cities he says if you take into
consideration the way that they're
disposed a tall building here a low
building here the way they cause the
streets to wind and change level they
look like more the product of chance or
an in the French for tune then as he
says the will of men applying their
reason the French phrase for that is
actually Pluto La Fortuna because I've
Volante to kick is ohm whose aunt the
reason because that lays on CD suppose a
so more the result of just chance
occurrences or different people using
their wills and reason but not
coordinating them together and so this
is going to be a problem if we're
thinking about the knowledge --is that
we're studying right disciplines how
much of it are we taking from what other
people have put together over time in
descartes zone time there were many
people say well listen Aristotle said
this and that and then this commentator
said this and that and Descartes would
say that's kind of like an ancient city
how do we know that Aristotle laid the
streets out in the right way how do we
know that these commentators built the
houses
where they needed to be maybe we need to
knock it all down and start again he
also talks about legislation and he says
you know look at societies where they
never really thought out their legal
code instead they just sort of added
laws here and there whenever they needed
them and he gives some you know example
as he says nations who are once
half-savage and only gradually became
more civilized whose legislation was
forced upon them by acts of criminal
mischief and legal disagreements he says
they cannot be as well governed as those
where a single prudent legislator
started by structuring the entire
society he uses as an example Sparta
he says Sparta Florida flourished it was
not because of the particular excellence
of each one of their laws as a matter of
fact some of their laws were kind of
weird he says but because they were all
laid down by one person they were all
directed to a single end now Descartes
is not endorsing the Spartan
Constitution or anything like that he is
saying when we apply this to knowledge
if we're trying to reconstruct the
foundations of knowledge we want to do
so systematically
we want to do so in such a way that this
discipline over here does not clash with
this discipline over here or within any
particular discipline we don't have a
bunch of different authorities all you
might say at war with each other over
who's right and who's wrong that's a
problem instead we want it to look more
like mathematics where we make gradual
progress and you know once somebody
introduces a proof for a theorem or a
procedure for doing something everybody
can look at it and examine it and say
aha you're right I see or they can they
can attack it and if they manage to
disprove it then it's gone right so take
heart assay
if we think about city planning if we
think about legislation and we apply
that to what we might call the Republic
of knowledge then we can start to see
how we get out of the problematic state
that we're in he also does tell us we we
don't see people pulling down all the
houses of a town for the sole purpose of
reconstructing them differently but we
do see many people having their own
houses demolished in order to rebuild
them and sometimes they have to do that
when it's falling down so we're going to
do this in a piecemeal way and we do
this by laying down good foundations so
if we want to use you know more
contemporary thing if you get an old
house you may actually have to gut it
and then bring everything up to proper
code you may actually have to demolish
the entire house put a new foundation
build a new house on the same property
so decart
is going to tell us that the individual
should focus on his own knowledge why is
a good point to ask this question why
shouldn't he focus on trying to change
everything all at once if an individual
realizes that things aren't always laid
out properly why shouldn't he get
involved in say city planning or at
legislation so they Kurt says I can't
approve of those metal meddlesome and
restless spirits who are called neither
by birth nor riches to take part in
public affairs you know forever plotting
some reform my and he says my project
has never extended between beyond
wishing to reform my own thoughts and to
build on a foundation which is mine
alone
so he's suggesting that the individual
when it comes to knowledge should try to
improve him or herself to find a way and
interestingly so this is the second part
here why did Descartes realize there's
this whole thing that
knowledge is like a city or a like
legislation why didn't you just remain
content with with what was there
he says there's two kinds of people
there there are people who he says
believing themselves cleverer than they
are cannot stop themselves jumping to
conclusions and they don't have enough
patience to govern their thoughts in an
orderly way with the result that once
they have allowed themselves to doubt
accepted principles and astray from the
common path they would never be able to
keep to the road that one must take to
proceed in the right direction and they
would remain lost all of their lives
these are the people who constantly have
projects they're always redoing things
and they think that it's a great thing
to always be doubting to be you know
a critical thinker as we say and there's
nothing wrong with critical thinking but
some people abuse that term right these
are the people who are always being a
devil's advocate and you ask them what
they they do in fact know or believe and
they really don't have much or what they
do have you look at it closely and
you're like well you don't have good
reason to believe that why are you
attacking this person over here when
what you have to say is just as
questionable as what they're saying so
that's the first kind of person the
second kind of person Descartes says is
at the other extreme says there are
those who having enough sense or modesty
to realize they're less capable of
distinguishing the true from the false
than certain others by whom they could
be guided must content themselves with
following the opinions of these others
rather than seeking better ones from
themselves so the first class they think
they're going to get it on their own
they're gonna make it up they're gonna
reinvent the wheel they're gonna come up
with the new system they're gonna fix
everything and they're mistaken about
that the second are more modest and they
say I don't really know everything maybe
I should get a book maybe I should see
what somebody who studies these sorts of
things has to say and follow them and
Descartes says listen I was that kind of
person I was the second type but there
was a problem
for me which meant that I had to become
a third type the type that he's actually
suggesting all of us should become so he
couldn't just follow the views of other
people the opinions the the doctrines
why not it came out of the realization
that there were differences of opinion
between all of these experts on so many
matters and so he tells us interestingly
I would have perhaps been in the second
category if I had had only one teacher
if he'd just studied under one person
and never looked at another fundamental
perspective he would have been fine or
he says if I had never learned about the
differences of opinion that have always
existed among the most learned but I did
learn about that and that threw me into
a confusion it's one thing to say okay I
don't have it all figured out so I'm
gonna follow somebody who I think has it
more figured out but what if you've got
five people all of whom say that they
have it more figured out and everybody
around you says that at least one of
them does and they don't agree with each
other in a case like that Descartes says
you have to provide your own guidance
you have to come up with your own
answers and he talks about this as yeah
this is a very nice thing he says I was
constrained to take on the task daunt
upon my men D'Amico and we are to lead
myself to guide myself to you know steer
myself you you might say into the right
paths and so this is what is going to
lead him ultimately to his famous method
but this is why he is pursuing the
method in the first place the goal being
to reconstruct the foundations of
knowledge to create something sort of
like within oneself a set of laws or a
newly erected city that would be all of
this beauty
full knowledge laid out properly once
and for all
you